sunken relics ghostly shipwrecks and
lost cities these aren't just wonders
found in fictional adventures beneath
the ocean's surface there are ruins
where people once roamed and shipwrecks
loaded with artifacts from another time
this is the domain of underwater
archaeology where researchers discover
and study human artifacts that slipped
into the sea they're not on a treasure
hunt underwater archaeology reveals
important information about ancient
climates and coastlines it tells us how
humans sailed the seas and what life was
like millennia ago so what exactly can
we find at shallow depths mingled in
with modern-day items we've discovered
all sorts of ancient artifacts this zone
contains evidence of how our ancestors
fished how they repaired their ships
disposed of their trash and even their
convicted pirates who were buried below
the tide line and it's not just our
recent history eight hundred thousand
year old footprints were found along the
shore in Norfolk Britain in these
shallow depths the remains of sunken
cities also loom up from the sea floor
deposited there by earthquakes tsunamis
and Earth's sinking plates almost every
sunken city can be found at these
shallow depths because the sea level has
changed little in the several thousand
years that city building civilizations
have existed for instance in shallow
waters off the coast of Italy lies
bhaiyya a Roman seaside town over 2,000
years old there it's possible to swim
among the ruins of structures built by
Rome's great families senators and
emperors and then there are shipwrecks
as ships grow too old for use they're
usually abandoned near shore in
out-of-the-way places like estuaries
rivers and shallow bays archaeologists
use these like a timeline to map a
harbors peaks and declines and to get
clues about the historic art of
shipbuilding at ross kea in denmark for
example five purposefully sunken vessels
feel how Vikings crafted their fearsome
long ships a thousand years ago when we
descend a bit further we reach the zone
where the deepest human structures lie
like ancient harbor walls and keys we
also see more shipwrecks sunk by storms
war and collisions we're still
excavating many of these wrecks today
like Blackbeard's ship which is
revealing secrets about life as an 18th
century pirate but past fifty feet there
are even deeper better preserved
shipwrecks like the wreck at Antikythera
which sank during the 1st century BC
when it was discovered it contains
statues trade cargo and also the
earliest known computer a mysterious
device called the Antikythera mechanism
that kept track of astronomical changes
and eclipses today
it gives archaeologists vital
information about the knowledge
possessed by the ancient Greeks it is in
this zone that we also begin to find
aircraft and submarines such as those
from the world wars plunging as deep as
200 feet we can find some of the
earliest and rarest signs of human
history prior to 5,000 years ago there
was a lot more dry land because glaciers
trapped much of the water that now forms
the sea our ancestors spread across
these lands and so on the seafloor we
find their camps stone tools and the
bones of animals they hunted these sites
give us invaluable knowledge about our
ancestors migration patterns hunting
methods and technologies in the deepest
zone no human has ever walked this area
has been submerged since well before
mankind evolved the only artifacts we
find are those that have drifted down
from above like NASA's Saturn 5 rocket
engines at 14,000 feet and the deepest
shipwrecks
the ocean is like a huge underwater
museum that constantly adds to our
knowledge about humanity with only a
fraction of it explored discoveries are
sure to continue long into the future